okay so this is the second video here's
the basics of how it works there's
basically two types of exercise high
intensity and low intensity this would
be sprinting to be walking yoga
stretching this is playing basketball
interval training hopping Stairmaster
hardcore and this is very low so you're
barely breathing you actually can't go
with the pulse rate because if the
nervous system is broken your pulse rate
might be low but you're huffing and
puffing so I'd rather go based on your
own subjective feeling how hard it is
and how go by your breathing basically
so low intensity workouts you can
actually talk to someone while you're
walking comfortably here you can't
you're huffing and puffing okay so this
is called without air because it's
called anaerobic without air because
you're actually burning more sugar and
I'll explain in a second this is called
aerobic exercise now people get
confusion because there's two
definitions of aerobic one is aerobic
type workouts which you're jumping
around high intensity but then the other
definition is the type of exercise that
uses a lot of oxygen so it means aerobic
means with air low intensity so when you
low intensity walking you're actually
doing aerobic type workouts okay so high
intensity low intensity now both of
these do burn sugar and both of them do
burn fat but let's start with the low
intensity right here the body will burn
up remember we talked about the sugar
calories being like 1,500 calories all
that's burned within the first 25
minutes of walking after the 25 minutes
of walking then the person will start
burning fat it's not a lot of fat but
it's a little fat it's still good to do
so people that work out 20-30 minutes a
day really only burn five minutes of fat
burn who had five minutes of actual fat
burning going on so
if you're going to rock you might as
well walk 45 or maybe 60 minutes okay
there's nothing wrong with walking in
the beginning because you want to key is
not overtraining the advantage of doing
this is because this is how you would do
stress low intensity workouts are really
better for stress than high intensity
because it's very relaxing to the body
and you're increasing a lot of breathing
oxygen without the stress see when you
go through stress you don't you deprive
yourself of oxygen so this is a way to
get the oxygen into your body and
actually protect your heart
is this is nothing wrong with high
intensity but it has to do with your
ability to tolerate it and handle it
many people don't have the ability to
handle hard core workout so for everyone
in this program they're going to start
walking and you're going to gradually
increase to high intensity over time so
with low intensity workouts you will not
burn any fat for the first twenty five
minutes then after that you will burn
actual fat so in other words let me get
this straight here the first 25 minutes
you'll burn sugar and then after that
you will burn fat so again if you're
going to walk walk for at least an hour
all right and I like the idea of working
walking outside and not with headphones
just looking at stuff and relaxing and
having a good time as compared to trying
to think about everything you want to
turn that off a little bit okay now the
high intensity it will also burn sugar
immediately so it's burning up out of
the sugar but you can't really do high
intensity for a long period of time
because your sugar will go out and then
this will turn into a byproduct called
lactic acid
okay so sugar turns lactic acid that's
why your muscles get really painful and
burning because of not lactic acid so
the more sugar that you burn the more
acid you will generate and then acid
decreases oxygen in the body alright so
can you burn fat with high intensity
absolutely
it only occurs 14 to 48 hours after the
workout during the deep sleep okay so
again the most fat that you can burn
with all exercise is really right here
high-intensity I'll show you how to do
it in a little bit but but it doesn't
happen right away it's delayed when
you're sleeping if you're sleeping and
there's certain barriers that occur that
stop you from doing that but the point
is that depending on what you're doing
and depending on the intensity intensity
is really the key thing between
everything and this fat is burned
through hormone interaction anyone can
burn sugar but the burn fat takes a very
specific condition in the body and we'll
get into the next video but I just
wanted to show you the difference
between high intensity low intensity and
how it works